mesdames et messieurs on me demande
souvent comment je choisis mes livres
comment distinguer les bons livres des
mauvais alors voilà je suis venu ce soir
pour vous révéler les trucs les secrets
des lecteurs professionnels qu'ils
soient critiques ou libraire les secrets
qui leur permettent de distinguer dans
la masse quotidienne des nouveautés de
distinguer les shaders et pour à l'appui
de même ma démonstration
je vais faire appel à un incontestable
chef-d'oeuvre un considérable chez
d'heure il s'agit du petit père est
illustré par l'exemple aux éditions jean
claude lattès
alors première premiers secrets ou
première loi fondamentale de la critique
littéraire tous les livres qui sortent
de l'imprimerie aubin à ligugé dans le
département de la vienne sont des shader
évidemment il arrive que d'autres
imprimerie en france publie de bons
livres mais je dois dire c'est assez
rare tandis que l'imprimerie
oh ben ali du g département de la vienne
ne publie que de que des bons livres
alors je vous observées dans les
librairies quand vous quand vous
choisissez vos livres jour remarqué que
vous reprenez la couverture vous
regardez surtout le nom de l'auteur le
titre du livre est le nom de l'éditeur
et bien c'est inutile car ces choses là
ne compte pas ce qui importe dans le
livre c'est l'imprimeur car non d'une
pipe
qu'est-ce qui fabrique le livre c'est
bien l'imprimeur non alors vous allez me
dire mais l'imprimeur ou est-ce qu'il
ait marqué et bien savez les les
éditeurs les auteurs sont des mecs tu
lui regardez la grosseur des caractères
et sans couverture
est-ce que l'imprimeur lui c'est un
modeste c'est un modeste et il marque
il marque son son nom en tout petits
caractères à la dernière page du livre
alors on va voir si ceux ci se livre est
un étal shaders et comme on risque de ne
pas me voir
drucker on élire les lire ce qu'il ya
marqué là à la fin de cet ouvrage
alors ses marques et achevé d'imprimer
par l'imprimerie oh ben ça suffit
scheider il sort de chez aubin shedden
deuxième secret ou deuxième loi loi
fondamentale et bien entendu de la
critique littéraire tout livre dont la
longueur est le double de la largeur - 7
cm est un chef-d'oeuvre elle et je le
dis tout de suite il n'y a pas
d'exception alors allé puiser dans vos
bibliothèques les chefs-d'oeuvre qui
susciteront et mesurer les vous allez
vérifier que cette loi est tout à fait
vrai par exemple la longueur de la bible
est le double de sa largeur - 7 cm la
longueur de madame bovary c'est le
double de sa largeur - 7 cm
la longueur de chaque chef-d'oeuvre de
ceux-là c'est le double de la largeur -
7 cm et don quichotte et bien
donquichotte c'est le la longueur du don
quichotte et le double de la largeur de
sancho pansa - 7 cm et me direz-vous
l'être et le néant de jean paul stars et
bien la longueur de lettres est le
double de la largeur du néant
- 7 cm
mesdames et messieurs ceci est un double
mètre pliant n'entrait jamais dans une
librairie sans être muni de cet
instrument
et si vous l'avez oublié chez vous
demandez celui du libraire il ne montre
pas ils le cachent misant toujours un
sur eux parce qu'autrement ils frayent
sont pas plus intelligents que les
autres alors bon on s'en sert aussi
alors nous allons mesurer
nous allons voir si le petit père est
répond à la loi que j'ai énoncé tout à
l'heure voici sa longueur 23 cm sa
largeur 15 cm 2 x qui s 30 - 7 égale 23
févr
c'est possible
je n'ai pas fini car il se peut que vous
ayez oublié vos lunettes ne puisse pas
voir le nom d'un primeur ou que vous
n'ayez pas sur vous le double mètre
alors dans ce cas là il nous reste une
possibilité c'est la dernière c'est de
poser le livre c'est de poser le livre
alors en effet il est tout à fait
remarquable que tous les chefs d'oeuvre
de la littérature française pèse entre
475 grammes et 5 125 g tous les livres
qui pèse moins de 475 grammes sont de
mauvais libre et où les lille qui pèse
plus de 525 g
ce sont des livres exécrable plus on se
rapproche des 500 grammes meilleur est
le lit d'où mon troisième secret ma
troisième loi fondamentale de la
critique littéraire tout livre qui se
rapproche de la livre est un
chef-d'oeuvre
alors j'ai des exemples significatifs 1
je les ai posé en devenir les pensées de
pascal 480 grammes
les mémoires d'hadrien le mari cure
senard 5 109 g les poésies complètes de
rimbaud 4 187 g eugénie grandet de
balzac 475 grammes à c'était juste un g
2 - et c'était un mauvais livre la
chartreuse de parme de stendhal 5 105 g
le discours d'un méthode de descartes 4
194 g
oss 117 cherche des cross 500 programmes
alors là à mon avis une erreur où ils
ont truqué la balance a sûrement bon
alors maintenant en tout cas ma balance
annuelle n'est pas truquée nous allons
peser le petit père est illustré par
exemple à la royan 200 g
300 g 400 g 450 grammes se rapprochent
470 g 480 g 4 181 grammes en coton peut
aller jusqu'à 2
3 voilà 4 183 g c'est exactement le
poids des pensées de pascal exactement
ils sont à égalité
m
même ces messieurs je vais m'y perds
donc la démonstration que le livre de
pierre perret et trois fois à
chef-d'oeuvre je vous demande
d'applaudir son auteur